ASSEMBLY MEMBER RACE NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
BARRICADE HAN BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
RYAN BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRADE GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAID ARTURO SMITH.
STONE T. CALAVERAS APPROVED VIA
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
THAT OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN
THE GALLERY. PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN EMAIL
YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD.
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. WE PRAY TO ALMIGHTY
GOD AND ETERNAL GOD. EVER
PRESENT TO ALL OUR UNDERTAKINGS
AND ALL OUR NEEDS. TOUCH EVERY
ASPECT OF OUR LIVES WITH YOUR
HOLINESS. ENDOW US WITH FAITH
AS WE BEGIN A NEW WEEK ON THIS
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. MAY YOUR DIVINE
WISDOM DIRECT ALL OF OUR
DELIBERATIONS AND BE REVEALED
AND ALL THE PROCEEDINGS. MAY
THE GRACIOUS WORK PRESERVE
PEACE PROMOTE HAPPINESS AN
INCREASE AN INCREASE IN THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. DEDICATION TO
INDUSTRY A SENSE OF COMPASSION
FOR OTHERS AND USEFUL
KNOWLEDGE. SO THAT THE
BLESSINGS OF SO MANY IN THE
STATE. MAY BE EXTENDED TO ALL
WITH EQUAL LIBERTY I MEAN.
THANK YOU MOM YES SIR WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER QUE HAN
SHE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER KING THANK YOU MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME AS WE SALUTE OUR
FLAG READY BEGIN. I PLEDGE TO.
ASIAN AMERICAN. JUST. IT IS.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO MONDAY JUNE TWENTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
ASSEMBLY READ AT ONE PM THE
HONORABLE COURSE FOR A MORE
ACTING SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CIEF LOOKS ACROSS AT
THE DESK REFLECTIVITY BONA
READING ROLL CALL THE ROLL
CALL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
AWARENESS MOVES. AND MS ABOUT
THEIR SECONDS. THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NINE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR MEDICAL LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES.
MEMBERS
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
MS REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BURKE AND WENT
TO HAVE THEIR CHILDREN SEATED
AT THEIR DESKS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THEY ARE
QUE HAND FONG SALAS AND THAT
WAR TO SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENT AND
MEMORY TODAY. GET WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR'S PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ITEMS SEVENTY FIVE SB
TWO THIRTY NINE SENATE BANKING
AND FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
COMMITTEE AND THE- ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR JONES.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY ROLLED NINETY SEVEN
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RE REFER ITEM SIXTY FOUR SP ONE
THIRTY THREE AND ITEM SIXTY
FIVE SB ONE FIFTY THREE TO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. PLEASE REMOVE ITEM
EIGHTY FOUR SB SEVEN TWENTY TWO
MELENDEZ FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND FURTHER I MOVED TO
RE REFER THE BILL TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SEVEN. MR FLOOR FOR
PURPOSE SIR THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WE ASKED WE WILL HOLD
YOU KNOW IT'S CONSENT NATURAL
CALL VOTE. MISTER FLOOR IS
WITHHOLDING. MS RAY IS LOOSE
AND MISTER GIBSON SECONDS. ON
THE REFERRAL. MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE MEMBERS. CLARK
WELL OVER THE ROLE. IS RAMOS IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. ED
MISTER FLOOR IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. MAYES RADIUS IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND MR FLORA A
NO VOTE THIS IS PROCEDURAL AND
TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES. HARTWELL.
CLOSER ALL EYES FORTY SEVEN
KNOWS TWELVE MOTIONWEAR FOR
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE AT GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS. MEMBERS. I
MISSED WHEN YOU HAVE SPECIAL
BHP'S AT YOUR DESK. AS THEY
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I JUST
WANTED TO DO IS MY TWO BOYS I
HAVE TAMI AND TIMOTHY THOMAS
TEN AND TO MAKE THESE EIGHT WHO
ARE HERE TODAY. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING OUR FORMER
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUE NOW SAN
DIEGO MAYOR TODD GLORIA HE'S IN
THE REAR CHAMBER. WELCOME BACK
TO THE GREEN CARPET SIR.
OKAY
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. THIS IS BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
CORKERY SENATE BILL FOUR FIFTY
THREE FIVE NINETEEN FOR THE
MINUTES THE READING OF THE
MINISTRY TIM OF THE MINUTES AND
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY TWO
WITHIN MINUTES. ALL BILLS WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. YEAH. MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN- ON THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
WE'RE GOING TO THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE THE START
TODAY. AND WE ARE GOING TO
START WITH. FILE ITEM. FIFTEEN
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN IS AJ ARE
FIVE BY MS RIVAS THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS WE
BOSS AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
WILD FREE ROAMING HORSES AND
BURROS. MEMBERS. PLEASE GIVE ME
ATTENTION AS RIVAS MS RIVAS YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
A. J. R. FIVE THAT I'M JOINT
OFFERING WITH ASSEMBLY MINORITY
LEADER MARIE WALDRON A'JA ARE
FIVE RECOGNIZE THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE FEDERAL WILD
FREE ROAMING HORSES AND BURROS
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE AND
URGES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
DECLARE A MORATORIUM ON ALL
WILD HORSE AND BURRO ROUNDUPS
IN CALIFORNIA SINCE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE U. S. FOREST
SERVICE HAS REMOVED ONE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN HORSES FROM
FEDERALLY PROTECTED LANDS AND
DEVIL'S GARDEN TERRITORY. OF
THEM MODOC NATIONAL FOREST
THESE HORSES ARE CURRENTLY
BEING SOLD FOR A DOLLAR EACH
WITH THE DAILY LIMIT OF TWENTY
FOUR TO EACH BUYER MANY IF NOT
ALL OF THEM WILL BE BOUGHT AND
SOLD FOR SLAUGHTER PROTECTION
GROUPS HAVE SAID THAT THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME IN NEARLY HALF A
CENTURY THE GOVERNMENT HAS SOLD
EQUINES FOR ANY PURPOSE.
INCLUDING SLAUGHTER. AJ ARE
FIVE IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TOWARDS PRESERVING
CALIFORNIA'S BEAUTIFUL WILD
HORSES AND BURROS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS RIVAS.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM
THREE OF US WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. I
WOULD LIKE TO AUTHORS. MEMBERS
FIRST ROLE WILL BE FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN BUSINESSES
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON A
CHAIR.
FIVE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE FORTY SIX
CO AUTHORS ADDED THIS IS AJ ARE
SO WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL
VOTE. CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF IT
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VETERANS ARE
TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY NINE KNOWS
THREE. THAT RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO TAKE UP. FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN.
ACR. NINETY SEVEN. AND THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO INDIA'S
INDEPENDENCE DAY. MISTER KALRA
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY CURRENT
CURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY SEVEN
IS OUR BODY'S ANNUAL
RECOGNITION OF INDIA'S
INDEPENDENCE DAY. THE
SIGNIFICANT NATIONAL HOLIDAY IN
INDIA THAT IS CELEBRATED BY
MANY INDIAN AMERICANS TO HONOR
HERITAGE CULTURE AND PAID
TRIBUTE. TO THE INDIA IS
INDIA'S FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY.
ON AUGUST FIFTEENTH NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN INDIA PROCLAIMED
ITS INDEPENDENCE OVER THE
ENDING OVER TWO HUNDRED YEARS
OF BRITISH COLONIAL RULE. AS
ONE OF THE THREE NATIONAL
HOLIDAYS IN INDIA INDEPENDENCE
DAY IS ONE OF THE COUNTRY'S
MOST IMPORTANT NATIONAL
HOLIDAYS AND HONORS INDIA'S
EMBRACE OF DEMOCRACY TOLERANCE
AND THE RULE OF LAW. WITH A
POPULATION OF MORE THAN ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION PEOPLE THE
REPUBLIC OF INDIA IS THE
WORLD'S LARGEST DEMOCRACY.
ENSURES A COMMITMENT TO THE
BASIC FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES OF
FREEDOM OPPORTUNITY AND JUSTICE.
AS THE WORLD'S OLDEST DEMOCRACY
AROSE LARGEST DEMOCRACY REST
RESPECTIVELY. THE UNITED STATES
AND INDIA SHARE COMMON VALUES
OF THESE TIES UP OSTER GROWTH
IN BOTH COUNTRIES. ACR NINETY
SEVEN IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO RECOGNIZE THE
POSITIVE RELATIONS AND
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN INDIA THE
UNITED STATES AND ITS PEOPLE.
AS YOU MAY RECALL OUR
CONNECTION WITH THE PEOPLE OF
INDIA TOUCHED MANY. WHEN THE
COUNTRY WAS EXPERIENCING ONE OF
THE DEADLIEST COVERT OPERATES
IN THE WORLD. AND IT WAS IN
DESPERATE NEED FOR LIFE SAVING
OXYGEN SUPPLIES. DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME I WAS GRATEFUL
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. SUPPLIES
INCLUDING OXYGEN CYLINDERS AND
CONCENTRATORS NONE OF THIS
WOULD'VE BEEN POSSIBLE FOR WERE
NOT THEY WERE NOT FOR THE FACT
THAT THE STATE TOOK SERIOUS
PRECAUTIONS TO STOP THE SPREAD
OF IT. TO MAKE ACCESS SUPPLIES
AVAILABLE IT ALSO WOULDN'T HAVE
HAPPENED IF IT WASN'T FOR THE
URGING OF SO MANY IN THE INDIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND THE
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP OUR STATE
HAS WITH THE NATION OF INDIA.
TO THE PEOPLE OF INDIA AND THE
MILLIONS WITH STRONG TIES TO
CALIFORNIANS. IT IS MY
PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT ACR NINETY
SEVEN. IN HONOR OF INDIA'S
INDEPENDENCE DAY. AND CELEBRATE
THE VAST CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY
INDIAN AMERICANS IN OUR GREAT
STATE THANK YOU. THEY WAS KALRA
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ACR NINETY SEVEN RECOGNIZING
INDIA'S INDEPENDENCE DAY. THIS
DAY CELEBRATES THE START
LARGEST DEMOCRACY IN THE WORLD
WITH ROUGHLY ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION PEOPLE. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT PEOPLE OF
ALL BACKGROUNDS HAD TO THE
CREATION OF THE IN THE REPUBLIC
IN NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. MY
DESERVES A LARGE HINDU SIKH AND
MUSLIM INDIAN POPULATION. MAYES
GROUPS FOR THE FOUNDATION TO
CREATING THE INDIAN REPUBLIC
IT'S A PROTOCOL AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE OUR STAFF WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
COOPER MS GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR NINETY
SEVEN AND THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN JOSE FOR BRINGING THIS
BOARD. I REPRESENT THE CITY OF
I. T. SHOW WHICH HAS A LARGE
INDIAN POPULATION AND ACTUALLY
HAS AN AREA DESIGNATED AS%
LITTLE INDIA. AREA CONTRIBUTES
A LOT TO MY COMMUNITY. ARTESIA
AND THE AMERICAN AND INDIAN
CULTURE ARE INTERWOVEN TOGETHER
CREATED A CALL FOR TAPESTRY
RIGHT IN MY OWN BACKYARD. IN
FACT ONE OF MY SMALL BUSINESS
HONOREES FOR THIS YEAR HAILS
FROM THE CITY OF ARTESIA. RICE
SOUTH THE OWNERS ABOUT THE
FIRES ON MARCH WHICH HAD SOME
OF THE BEST INDIAN SWEETS. AND
OTHER DELICIOUS FOOD INCLUDING
DUBLIN BETWEEN MEXICAN AND
INDIAN FOOD WITH A SIDE THE F.
ANTHOPOULOS- AND THEIR VERSION.
OUT THERE STRONGLY RECOMMEND
YOU VISIT. TODAY WE COULD UP
TODAY IN TRIBUTE TO THE MANY IN
THE INTRANSIGENCE. I WANTED TO
SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT IN THE
INDEPENDENCE. TODAY WE
COMMEMORATE THE STRUGGLES THAT
THE PEOPLE OF INDIA AND THIRD
IN ORDER TO GAIN THE ABILITY TO
GOVERN THEMSELVES. TO SAY THEIR
OWN FAITH INTO HAVE LOST IN THE
GOVERNMENT THAT REFLECTS THE
PEOPLE OF INDIA. THE RIGHT TO
HAVE A GOVERNMENT OF THE PEOPLE
BY THE PEOPLE IS A BELIEVE THAT
THE PEOPLE OF BOTH INDIA AND
THE UNITED STATES UNDERSTAND
ALL TOO WELL. THEIR HISTORY AND
THEIR CULTURE AS WITH MANY
CULTURESTHAT HAVE DECIDED TO
CALL THE STATE THEIR HOME ONLY
MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE BY RENT.
AND MORE COLORFUL. ALL OF THIS
REMINDS OF- HOW TRULY RICH WE
ARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. MARCUS
HE'S NEVER AND IS A NEVER
ENDING JOURNEY THAT REQUIRES
ALL OF US TO KEEP WORKING AT
IT. AND TO KEEP MOVING FORWARD.
EVERY CELEBRATION OF OUR
DIVERSE CITY FEELS LIKE AN ACT
OF RESISTANCE AND THEY GIVE ME
HOPE. THAT'S WHY I'M PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND
CELEBRATE THIS DAY OF. WITH THE
INDIAN COMMUNITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS GARCIA.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MISTER KALRA YOU
MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU WISH THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU TO
MY COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE IN
SUPPORT OF THE RESOLUTION AS
THE FIRST INDIAN AMERICAN IN
THE HISTORY OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IS MY HONOR TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR AN AYE
VOTE FOR ACR NINETY SEVEN AND
REQUEST OF THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CALL AUTHORS. MISTER
KALRA IS REQUESTED THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
CARPOOL OF THE ROLL. NUMBERS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. THE
CLERK WILL. SAY NAY THE EYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. AND NOW MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM TWENTY. FILE ITEM TWENTY
AS HR FIFTY EIGHT BY DR CORK
FROM MS REYES DESK CLERK WILL
READ. POSSIBLE SOLUTION FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO AMERICAN
MUSLIM APPRECIATION AND
AWARENESS MONTH DR PERKY. GOOD
AFTERNOON SPEAKER IN MEMBERS I
AM PROUD TO ONCE AGAIN AUTHOR
RESOLUTION THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE AMERICAN
MUSLIM COMMUNITY. H. R. FIFTY
EIGHT RECOGNIZES AUGUST AS
AMERICAN MUSLIM APPRECIATION
AND AWARENESS MONTH. ALL
AMERICAN MUSLIMS HAVE SERVED
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATORS
SCIENTISTS. LEADERS IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY AND
MEDICAL RESEARCHERS THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS EXTEND NATIONALLY
AND GLOBALLY. ERICA MUSLIMS ARE
PUBLIC SERVANTS TEACHERS
DOCTORS VETERANS SOCIAL WORKERS
AND STUDENTS YET THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN AND
CONTINUES TO BE THE TARGET OF
RASMEA DISCRIMINATION ASSAULTS
FOR NO OTHER REASON THAN BEING
MUSLIM. DATA COMPILED BY THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS HIGHLIGHTS INST
INSTANCES OF DISCRIMINATION AND
HARASSMENT IN SCHOOLS AND
WORKPLACES DUE TO RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS AND PHYSICAL APPEARANCE
AND THEN FRANK. THE SIKH
COMMUNITY IN PARTICULAR GET-
MISTAKEN FOR MUSLIMS AND ARE
BEATEN FOR THAT PLEASE AS IF
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
PROBLEMS. AT THE COUNCIL ALSO
REPORTED INCIDENTS OF HATE
INCIDENTS ON THE FORM OF
VANDALIZE MOSQUES AND COMMUNITY
CENTERS THREATENING PHONE CALLS
AND LETTERS AGAINST MEMBERS OF
THE AMERICAN MUSLIM COMMUNITY.
THIS IS UPSETTING AND
UNACCEPTABLE AND IS WHY OF
INTRODUCED HR FIFTY EIGHT. THIS
IS CALIFORNIA STANDING IN
SOLIDARITY WITH OUR MUSLIM
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. THANK YOU
DR CORK. MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF HR FIFTY EIGHT FOR
ALL THE REASONS THAT OUR
COLLEAGUE DESCRIBED WE ARE VERY
PRIVILEGED HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TIME SUCH A VIBRANT
AND DIVERSE MUSLIM AMERICAN
COMMUNITY THAT HAS CONTRIBUTED
SO MUCH TO OUR STATE. OF COURSE
PART OF THAT COMMUNITY IS THE
AFGHAN COMMUNITY WHICH AND OUR
THOUGHTS ARE WITH THEM AS WE
CONTEMPLATE ALL THE HORRIFYING
SCENES THAT ARE TAKING PLACE IN
AFGHANISTAN TODAY AND FOR
SENDING OUR BEST WISHES AND
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS TO THOSE
MEMBERS OF OUR AFGHAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHO'S WHO THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE IMPACTED BY THIS
WE OF COURSE APPRECIATE THE
SOLIDARITY WITH THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY I'M VERY PRIVILEGED
TO REPRESENT A VIBRANT AND
DIVERSE MUSLIM COMMUNITY IN THE
WEST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY THEY
HAVE CONTRIBUTED SO MUCH TO OUR
COMMUNITY. SO MUCH TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF IN THE JEWISH CAUCUS
URGE A STRONG STEP SUPPORT VOTE
IN SUPPORT OF HR FIFTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL. I SEE
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. DR PERKINS EVEN
CLOSE IF YOU WISH YES THE
CALIFORNIA TO STATE THAT THE
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE OF ITS
DIVERSE POPULATION IMPORTANT
WITH KNOWLEDGE AND HONOR THE
MANY DIVERSE COMMUNITIES THAT
MAKE CALIFORNIA AND OUR NATION
A BETTER PLACE TO LIVE AND
WORK. I WOULD REQUEST LIKE TO
REQUEST THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS INVITE YOU
TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES FROM SAN
JOSE AND STANDING WITH OUR
MUSLIM BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND
VOTE ON HR FIFTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DR WORK DR PARK
IS REQUESTING THAT THE FIRST
ROLE THE UP OF CO AUTHORS
CARPOOL OF NARAL. MEMBERS THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR. FIFTY
EIGHT THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL THERE ARE
FIFTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS ADDED
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP SOME
AMENDMENTS ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. WE HAVE
AMENDMENTS ON SEVEN THIRDS.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY.
SENATE BILL THREE THREE ONE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CORKERY WITH IMMENSE SENATE
BILL THREE THIRTY ONE WITH THE
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES ISRAEL'S ON THE MEMONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THESE
ARE CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS WHICH
SIMPLY CLARIFY THE BILL IS NOT
RETROACTIVE AND THE SEVERANCE
AMOUNT MAY BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ITEM. I THINK THIS RACE THAT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE DOCKED IT
FILLS OUT TO PRINCE. AND BACK
ON FILE. AND MEMBERS WERE GOING
TO MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
FIFTY NINE FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE
S. B. TWO NINETY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CORKERY
WITH IMMENSE. SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY WITH THE MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA MS
CLARK SILVA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE FOR
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS TO SP TWO
NINETY AUTHORED BY SENATOR
SKINNER WHICH IMPROVES AND
CLARIFIES CALIFORNIA'S DENSITY
BONUS HOUSING LAW THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND ARE BEING ACCEPTED
BY THE AUTHOR AT THE REQUEST OF
THE COMMUNITY DEPARTMENT. THIS
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. BYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE BENEFITS
ARE DOTTED BILLS OUT THE
PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP. A FEW
CONCURRENCE ITEMS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE THIS IS FILE ITEM NINE. ON
THE CONCURRENCE. FILE AB. FIVE
FORTY ONE AB FIVE FORTY ONE
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FORTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AND OTHERS IMMACULATE IN
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER
TREATMENT MR BERMAN EMAIL BUT-
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. AB
FIVE FORTY ONE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
PROGRAMS TO ASSESS PATIENTS FOR
TOBACCO USE AND OFFER TREATMENT
OR REFERRALTO TREATMENT. FOR
TOBACCO USE DISORDER
INDIVIDUALS WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DISORDERS ARE MORE THAN
TWICE AS LIKELY TO SMOKE
CIGARETTES AS INDIVIDUALS
WITHOUT SUCH DISORDERS AND ARE
MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM TOBACCO
RELATED ILLNESS THEN FROM THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITION
THAT BRINGS THEM TO TREATMENT.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
IN CLARIFYING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS BERMAN. SENIOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS OUT OF VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRABLE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE TALBERT
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER. TEN
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB SIX
ELEVEN BY MISS CLARK SILVA
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK SILVA AN ACT RELATING TO
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION. MS
CLARK SILVA YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
HERE TODAY TO REQUEST YOUR
CONCURRENCE IN THE SENATE
ADVANCEMENTS TO AB SIXTY ELEVEN
AB SIX ELEVEN WILL ALLOW
PARTICIPANTS IN THE SECRETARY
OF STATE SAFE AT HOME PROGRAM
TO USE THEIR SAFE AT HOME
ADDRESS FOR COMMUNICATIONS WITH
THEIR H. AWAY. THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONFORM TO THIS
DEFINITION THERE'S BEEN NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS CLARK SILVA. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CARPAL OF THE ROLE. IT IS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSER ALL
TIED TO THE I. SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. AND THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE. AB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE. CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT THIRTY ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND OTHERS
AND ACCOLADES TO THE CALIFORNIA
RETAIL FOOD GROUP. DR WOULD YOU
MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB EIGHT THIRTY ONE
IS A COMMITTEE BILL SPONSORED
BY THE CALIFORNIA RETAIL FOOD
SAFETY COALITION WHICH MAKES
VARIOUS TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO THE CALIFORNIA
RETAIL FOOD CODE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WHAT. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
CARCLUB THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS.
IT IS AT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THEIR DESIRE TO VOTE.
MARKWELL CLOSER ALL THE TIME
BUT I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO THESE TOP OF THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE. THIS IS THE
SENATE THIRD READING. FILE
ITEMS TWENTY ONE THROUGH TWENTY
NINE PASS AND RETAIN WE'VE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE SB FIVE FORTY EIGHT.
AND A COVERING. SENATE BILL
FIVE FORTY EIGHT BY CENTER
EGGMAN AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
AND TRANSPORTATION MISSPELLED
QUE HAN THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS SB FIVE FORTY EIGHT
IS A SIMPLE BILL THE FOLLOWS UP
ON AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT OF A
FEW YEARS AGO BY THEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN. THE BILL
ESTABLISH THE TRI VALLEY SAN
JOAQUIN REGIONAL RAIL AUTHORITY
RESPONSIBLE FOR LINKING THE
EAST TRAIN AND BART THE
AUTHORITY HAS SENSE IDENTIFY TO
TRAIN PROJECT VALLEY LINK THAT
WILL CONNECT WITH ACE AT THE
LAPTOP STATION AND CONNECT WITH
BART AT THE DUBLIN PLEASANTON
STATION THE PROJECT WOULD
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE
CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY IN THE BAY AREA.
AND PLANNING IS WELL UNDER WAY
THIS PARTICULAR BILL SIMPLY
MAKES THREE CLARIFYING CHANGES
TO THE UNDERLYING LAW FIRST IT
CLARIFIES THAT THE AUTHORITY
CAN OPERATE THE TRAIN SECONDLY
IT ELIMINATES THE REQUIREMENT
THE CONNECTION MUST BE IN THE
TRI VALLEY AS THE BEST
CONNECTION IS ELSEWHERE AND
LASTLY THE BILL ESTABLISHES THE
AUTHORITY AS A RAIL TRANSIT
DISTRICT. THIS IS A PROJECT OF
TREMENDOUS REGIONAL PORTENTS
FOR TRANSIT INTEGRATION AND
ALIGNS WITH OUR STATE RAIL
PLAN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
PRIVATE. THANK YOU IS BETTER
CARE. C. NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CORPORAL. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL. TELL YOU
WHAT I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. PASS
RETAIN OUR FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO
AND FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE
ITEM. THIRTY THREE SB THIRTEEN
CORPORATE SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
BY SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING
TO LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION OF
THE CAREERS OF EITHER OF THE
AFFECT ME DEEPLY MS
AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS SB THIRTEEN
WHILST IN THE SUNSET OF A PILOT
PROGRAM IN NAPA AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTIES. ALLOWING
LEFT GOES TO AUTHORIZE CITY OR
DISTRICT SERVICES OUTSIDE URBAN
BOUNDARIES THIS BILL RESPONSE
TO NAPA COUNTIES NEED TO
ACCOMMODATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER
MEMBER DOGS AB FOUR OH TWO FROM
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN ESTABLISH
A PILOT PROGRAM IN NAPA AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTIES ALLOWING
THE LEFT GO. TO AUTHORIZE A
CITY OR DISTRICT PROVIDE
SERVICES OUTSIDE ITS
BOUNDARIES. AS LONG AS THE
EXTENSION WILL NOT ADVERSELY
IMPACT AGRICULTURE OR OPEN
SPACE. GIVEN THE PUBLIC
BENEFITS AFFORDED TO THIS PUB.
FOR A PILOT PROGRAM IN BOTH
COUNTIES IN THE LIKELY HOLD
HOOD OF THESE COUNTIES WILL
AGAIN REQUIRE THE FLEXIBILITY
AFFORDED BY THE PILOT PROGRAM.
IT IS APPROPRIATE. TO EXTEND
THE PROVISIONS OF AB FOUR OH
TWO. LOW CONTROLS PRESERVED AS
A CITY COUNTY AND LAUGHTER
WOULD ALL NEED TO APPROVE WITH
RESPECTIVE PROJECTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. CLICK LIBERAL
MEMBERS- DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
HER TWELVE. CLOTHES ARE ALL
TIED UP BUT I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO. ON THE BILL THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASS RETAIN OUR
FILE ITEMS THIRTY FOUR AND.
THIRTY FIVE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTY SIX BY MISS DOLLY. WE
PASS TEMPORARILY. FILE ITEMS.
THIRTY SEVEN. THROUGH FORTY TWO
THAT'S THIRTY SEVEN THROUGH
FORTY TWO. PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM FORTY THREE SB TWO
NINETY FOUR BY MR O'DONNELL THE
CORPORATE. SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY FOUR BY CENTER LEYVA AND
OTHERS AN ECHOING THE PUBLIC
RETIREMENT MAKING
APPROPRIATION- FOR MR O'DONNELL
EMAIL BUT- THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB. SB TWO NINE
FOUR REMOVES THE TWELVE YEAR
MAXIMUM SERVICE CREDIT CAP.
THAT CAN BE EARNED AS AN
EDUCATOR. PUBLIC EMPLOYEES AND
EDUCATORS IN CALIFORNIA CAN'T
TAKE A LEAVE FROM THEIR JOB TO
ACT AS A STEWARD OR
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
RESPECTIVE STATE OR NATIONAL
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION. THESE
UNION REPRESENTATIVES MAY SPEND
SEVERAL YEARS AWAY FROM THE
OFFICE OR CLASSROOM ADVOCATING
FOR IMPROVED WORKING CONDITIONS
AND EMPLOYEE RIGHTS. WELL
SERVICE CAP DOES NOT APPLY TO
OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING PEACE OFFICERS
FIREFIGHTERS AND CITY AND
COUNTY EMPLOYEES IT DOES APPLY
TO EDUCATORS. SB TWO NINETY
FOUR SIMPLY REMOVES THIS TWELVE
YEAR CAP TO ENSURE THAT
EDUCATORS HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEES. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER DONALD
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CARCLUB LAUREL ALL
MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
SOLVE EVER SERVICE OUT OF L.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
EYES FIFTY THREE KNOWS TWELVE
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS.
FORTY FOUR FORTY FIVE AND FORTY
SIX PASS RETAIN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN SB THREE FIFTY
THREE CORKERY. SENATE BILL
THREE FIFTY THREE BY CENTER
ROTH INACCURATE IN HOSPICE MS
IRWIN EMAIL BUT THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB FIVE
THREE FIVE THREE SIMPLY EXTENDS
THE SUNSET OF THE PALLIATIVE
CARE PILOT PROGRAM UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN. THE PILOT PROGRAM
AUTHORIZES A LICENSE HOSPICE
PROVIDES PALLIATIVE CARE TO A
PATIENT WHO CONTINUES TO
RECEIVE CURATIVE TREATMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MS IRWIN. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CARCLUB RURAL. THE
CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
AND ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERSWE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE GREEN CARPET AT THIS
TIME.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS OR
GREATER PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MR KAY HAD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF AN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTEEN
CONSTITUENT BUT MORE IMPORTANT
WE FORMER CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND SENATOR RICHARD
RAINEY WHO DIED PEACEFULLY IN
HIS SLEEP ON JULY FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
TWO. RICHARD OR DICK TO HIS
FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY WAS BORN
IN OREGON IN NINETEEN THIRTY
EIGHT TO A FAMILY OF LOCKERS
AND SPENT HIS YOUNG LIFE IN
LUMBER CAMPS. RICHARD BEGAN HIS
LIFELONG PUBLIC SERVICE BY
JOINING THE NAVY WHERE HE
SERVED FOR FOUR YEARS. AFTER
HIS MILITARY SERVICE RICHARD
JOINED THE CONTRA COSTA
SHERIFF'S OFFICE AND WAS
ELECTED SHERIFF IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT AS SURE IF HE WAS
A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR VICTIMS
AND WELL RESPECTED BY HIS
COLLEAGUES HE WAS ELECTED TO
THEN DISTRICT FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY
SEATS IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO.
FOLLOWED BY THE SENATE SEAT IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX WHERE HE
SERVED UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
SENATOR RAINY WAS DEDICATED TO
SERVING HIS DISTRICT AND
WORKING ACROSS THE AISLE
PARTICULARLY FOCUSING ON PUBLIC
SAFETY AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ISSUES. AFTERHIS TIME IN
OFFICE HE SERVED AS A REGIONAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT DURING THE GEORGE
W. BUSH ADMINISTRATION AND
REMAINS ENGAGED IN LOCAL
POLITICS IN HIS COMMUNITY FOR
THE REST OF HIS LIFE. DICK IS
SURVIVED BY HIS THREE CHILDREN
FOUR STEP CHILDREN AND TWELVE
GRANDCHILDREN. HE WAS A KIND
LOVING AND RELIABLE FATHER
GRANDFATHER AND HUSBAND TO HIS
WIFE TO. COLLEAGUES I ASK YOU
TO REMEMBER THIS PUBLIC SERVANT
WHO LIKE ALL OF US CAME HERE TO
SERVE HIS CONSTITUENTS WITH
INTEGRITY AND REMAIN DEDICATED
TO HIS VALUES TO THE VERY END.
MAY HIS MEMORY BE A BLESSING.
THANK YOU AS BURKE A. M.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOG YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. BUT HE
WAS A SPEAKER. TODAY I RISE TO
ASK THE ASSEMBLY TO ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF KERN COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPUTY PHILIP JESSE
CAMPUS A TRUE AMERICAN HERO WHO
LEFT US FAR TOO SOON. PHILIP
WAS BORN TO LEAD ANY COMMITTED
HIS LIFE TO PROTECTING AND
SERVING OTHERS AT EASE BIGGEST
AT HIGH SCHOOL HE LET THEIR
FOOTBALL TEAM AS OUR
QUARTERBACK. HE SERVED OUR
COUNTRY IN AFGHANISTAN AS A
PROUD MARINE. HE GRADUATED AS
THE TOP OVERALL RECRUIT IN HIS
CLASS. AT THE KERN COUNTY
SHERIFF'S RAINING ACADEMY HE
DUTIFULLY SERVED KERN COUNTY AS
A DEPUTY SHERIFF AND SWAT TEAM
OPERATOR FOR FIVE YEARS. FOR
MANY OF US. IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
FULLY UNDERSTAND THE DEVOTION
AN EXTRAORDINARY SELFLESSNESS
PHILIP HAD AND DEDICATING HIS
LIFE. TO PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITY AND THOSE HE LOVED.
LATE LAST MONTH IN MOSCOW
PHILIP LOSSES LIFE IN THE LINE
OF DUTY PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITY. NO WORDS CAN
ADEQUATE DESCRIBED HIS BRAVERY
COURAGE AND VALOR. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE CRISTINA
AND HIS THREE CHILDREN ELI.
KAMALA ANIL LISA. FATHER JESSE
MOTHER CHRISTINE SISTER ADRIANA
IN KALISPELL MEMBERS WHO LEFT.
AS A DECORATED MARINE VETERAN
AND A VALUED MEMBER OF THE KERN
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE WHAT HE
WAS ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH IN HIS
TIME WITH US IS NOTHING SHORT
OF INCREDIBLE. AN IMPRESSIVE. I
ASKED THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED TODAY IN THE MEMORY
OF CURRENT K. DEPUTY PHILIP
CAMPUS. THANK YOU MR FONG MR
SALIHU TO ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS A GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THAT
ALSO RISE TODAY TO SPEAK IN A
GERMAN IN MEMORY OF. KERN
COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFF BILL
JESSE CAMPUS WHO FELL IN THE
LINE OF DUTY ON JULY TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THE
AGE OF THIRTY FIVE. YOU KNOW
ANSWERING THE CALL TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITY. BILL WAS BORN ON
JANUARY TWENTY THIRD. NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX WITH LOVING PARENTS
JESSE. INTERESTING POMPOUS. THE
FAMILY OF FOUR WAS COMPLETE
WITH THE BIRTH OF THEIR- A
PHILIP SISTER. ADRIANA PHILIP
ATTENDED EAST BAKERSFIELD HIGH
SCHOOL- WERE EXCELLED IN BOTH
FOOTBALL AND ACTUALLY BECAME
THE STARTING QUARTERBACK IN
SOPHOMORE YEAR. AFTER
GRADUATING PHILLIP AND LISTED
IN THE MARINE CORPS'S WHERE HE
WAS THEN DEPLOYED AFGHANISTAN
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT. HE
CONTINUED HIS CAREER IN THE
MARINE CORPS AS A DRILL
INSTRUCTOR. AND WAS AWARDED THE
NAVY AND MARINE CORPS
ACHIEVEMENT MEDAL COMBAT ACTION
RIBBON AFGHANISTAN CAMP
CAMPAIGN MEDAL AND NUMEROUS
OTHER METALS RATHER SERVICE. IN
TWENTY ELEVEN FILLED MARRIED
THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE CRISTINA
NICOLE VARGAS. IMMEDIATELY
BECOMING A FATHER TO THEIR SON
ELI. SOON THE FAMILY GREW AS
THEY WELCOMED TWO DAUGHTERS
CAMILLERI WHOSE AND LISA MAY.
AFTER BEING HONORABLY
DISCHARGED FROM THE MARINES IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN PHILIP AND HIS
FAMILY MOVED BACK TO
BAKERSFIELD. REJOIN THE KERN
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
PHILIP HAD NUMEROUS ROLES THERE
INCLUDING PATROL DEPUTIES SWAT
TEAM OPERATOR RECRUIT TRAINING
OFFICER AN HONOR GUARD MEMBER.
OUTSIDE OF WORK FILL VOLUNTEER
THIS TIME AS AN INSTRUCTOR AND
MENTOR TO THE YOUTH INVOLVED IN
THE DEVIL PUPS PER
ORGANIZATION. WHERE HE MADE A
LASTING IMPACT CHALLENGING
EDUCATING. AND HELPING YOUNG
BOYS AND GIRLS LEARN SELF.
CONFIDENCE AND RESPONSIBILITY.
PHILIP SERVICE COMMUNITY FOR
FIVE YEARS UNTIL HIS END OF
WATCH ON JULY TWENTY FIFTH OF
THIS YEAR PHILIPPUS RIDE BY HIS
WIFE CHRISTINE AS CHILDREN YOU
LIKE CAMILLA ANALYSTS AND LISA
HIS SISTER ADRIANA HERNANDEZ
HIS PARENTS JESSE AND CHRISTINE
AND REVERSE AUNTS UNCLES NIECES
NEPHEWS AND COUSINS. WILLFULLY
REMEMBER FOREVER FOR LOVING
HONORING AND BEING DEDICATED TO
HIS FAMILY THE YEAR BEFORE AND
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY-
I CAN TELL YOU MEMBERS WHEN
THEY HAD A VIGIL OUT OF THE
CITY OF LOS GO WE NEVER SAW
SUCH AN OUTPOURING OF NOT ONLY
LOVE AND RESPECT WITH SOMEBODY
THAT WE KNEW AND- WHO BECAUSE
OF HIS SERVICE AND ANSWERED THE
CALL HIS LIFE WAS CUT SHORT.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT THIS. BODY ADJOURNED
IN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER. MISTER SAUCIER
AGAIN RECOGNIZED FOR AN
ADDITIONAL. ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY MISTER CELIS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- I RISE AGAIN TO
CHEN ALSO IN THE MEMORY OF A
DEAR FRIEND OF MINE DANNY
MICHAEL READ THE WHO PASSED
AWAY ON JULY TWENTY SIX TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT THE AGE OF FIFTY
SEVEN YOU KNOW DANNY WAS BRN
IN LOS GO. ON SEPTEMBER EIGHTH
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE AND SPENT
MOST OF HIS LIFE IN HIS
HOMETOWN. AFTER GRADUATING FROM
LAW SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
LISTED IN THE UNITED STATES
ARMY. HE SERVED IN THE ARMY FOR
THREE YEARS. AND WAS DISCHARGED
AS A CORPORAL. IT WASN'T LONG
AGO THAT HE MET HIS WIFE PETRA.
AND THE TWO WOULD SOON RAISE
THEIR OWN KIDS IN LAW SCHOOL AS
WELL. UPON RETURNING TO LAW
SCHOOL HE BECAME A BUS DRIVER
FOR THE LAW SCHOOL UNION
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND
HE WOULD BE KNOWN AS DANNY THE
BUS DRIVER. AND ENJOYED THE
JOB. A MENTALLY YOU CAN HEAR ME
TALK ABOUT IT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT HE WOULD TALK ABOUT IT
WITH SUCH. ENTHUSIASM IS THERE
BECAUSE I GOT TO KNOW ALL THE
FAMILIES IN TOWN. DANNY WAS
INCREDIBLY ACTIVE IN TOWN.
BECOMING COMMANDER OF THE VFW
POST SIX SEVEN FOUR TWO. USE
THAT POSITION TO BETTER IS
COMMUNITY. HOSTING THE ANNUAL
WASH GO CAR SHOW. AND PANCAKE
BREAKFASTS. AT THE VFW HALL
WOULD RAISE. MONEY FOR
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. DANNY
ALSO SPENT TIME VOLUNTEERING AT
THE RONALD MCDONALD HOUSE. IN
BAKERSFIELD AND SERVED AS A
HOST FAMILY FOR THE LOSS
BECAUSE BASEBALL TEAM. THE
RESERVE. DANNY WAS A LEADER IN
THE COMMUNITY SERVING TEN YEARS
AS A WALK AGAIN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER. AND SAT ON
THE WALL BECAUSE THE PRISON
COMMUNITY BOARD. HE RECEIVED
MANY REPORTS OVER THE YEARS BUT
ONE OF ITS HIGHEST HONORS. WAS
BEING NAMED THE WALKER GRAND
MARSHAL. OF TWENTY NINETEEN
ALONGSIDE HIS WIFE PETRA. WHEN
HE'S NOT BUSY HELPING HIS
NEIGHBORS DANNY LOVE TO DRIVE
OVER TO THE BAY AREA. AND EVEN
THOUGH HE WAS FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY HE LOVE THE GIANTS THEY
LOVE THE FORTY NINERS. AND I
REMEMBER HIM ALWAYS TALKING TO
ME ABOUT EITHER ONE OF THOSE
GAMES. THEN HE LEAVES BEHIND
HIS WIFE- PETROL RATHER HIS TWO
CHILDREN JOSE ARANDA AND
VICTORIA AND A GRANDSON. A
JACKSON RATHER. ASSET WE
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY AND-
JUST TO THE FAMILY I JUST WANT
TO SAY THERE'S MUCH LOVE I WILL
ALWAYS REMEMBER DANNY- AND- IT
JUST CAME AS SUCH A FACT
BECAUSE I JUST TALKED TO HIM. I
JUST A FEW WEEKS BEFORE JUST
BEFORE HIS PASSING AND WE WERE
FACETIMING. AT ONE OF THE
COMMUNITY EVENTS OF THE PANCAKE
BREAKFAST FOR THE VFW. AND JUST
WHAT HE'S ONE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS JUST FULL OF LIFE
AND FULL OF LOVE FOR COMMITTEE
BUT ALWAYS WANTED TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND HE WAS NEVER
AFRAID. TO CALL OUT SOME AND
JUSTICE STUDIES LAW HE WAS
NEVER AFRAID TO CALL IS A
FAMILY MEMBER OR A COUNCIL
MEMBER ANYBODY HE SAW WAS IN A
POSITION TO ACTUALLY HELP THE
COMMUNITY AND I WILL. FOREVER
MISS MY FRIEND ANY OF THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS SALAS.
YEAH MISTER WARD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IS WITH A HEAVY HEART
TODAY THAT I RISE TO INTERN IN
THE MEMORY O NANCY JAMISON WHO
LEFT US EARLY LAST MONTH. NEAR
THE ATTENDED LEWIS AND CLARK
COLLEGE AND STANFORD UNIVERSITY
AND FOR THE PAST TWO DECADES
SHE HAS BEEN SYNONYMOUS WITH
PHILANTHROPY AND COMMUNITY
INVESTMENT IN SAN DIEGO. SHE
LED SENIOR GRANT MAKERS NOW SAN
DIEGO CATALYST AS THE PRESIDENT
AND CEO UNDER HER LEADERSHIP
THE NETWORK BLOSSOM TO SUPPORT
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS FOUNDATIONS
FUNDERS GIVING CIRCLES AND
IMPACT INVESTORS SUPPORTING
OVER TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. HER WORK A SPARK
POWERFUL TEAMS IN OUR REGION
WITH HER IMPACT IN OUR
COMMUNITY TO BE FELT FOR YEARS
TO COME. SHE INSTITUTED A
UNIQUE IMPORTANT CULTURE SHIFT
THAT PHILANTHROPIC AND
NONPROFIT PRACTICES COULD DO
BETTER SHE SPOKE OF
UNDERSTANDING THE HISTORY AND
RESPONSIBILITY OF WEALTH AND
THE IMPERATIVE TO POINT YOU
TOWARD A MORE EQUITABLE FUTURE
AND RECKON WITH INEQUALITY AND
RACISM. NANCY WAS COMMITTED TO
ADVANCING SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
EQUITY AND SOCIAL JUSTICE FUND
IS NOW ESTABLISHED IN HER NAME
SO THAT THE WORK IMPORTANT TO
HER AND TO US ALL ME CONTINUE.
SHE LED WITH AUTHENTICITY GRACE
AND STEADFASTNESS AND MOTIVATED
OTHERS TO DO THE SAME PLEASE
JOIN ME IN KEEPING NANCY
JAMISON ANDOUR FAMILY. AND OUR
THOUGHTS AS WE ENTER IN HER
MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER WARD. MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES OF THE DESK TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. ALL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
WITH THE RED WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY AUGUST
SEVENTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY AUGUST EIGHTEENTH
SECOND SESSION. THURSDAY AUGUST
NINETEEN FOR SESSION IS AT NINE
AM ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUE.
SEEING AND HEARING OR FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MISTER
BLOOM MOVES AND MR LACKEY
SECOND STAFF THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY.
AUGUST THE NINETEENTH AT NINE
AM IN THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.